hey youtubers is Charlie awesome news
they finally confirmed the Supergirl
flash crossover I guess we're calling it
super flash but they've already
announced a couple of details here's the
most important stuff flash is going to
travel the multiverse to National City
and help Supergirl out with one of her
storylines we don't know what the exact
storyline is gonna be but the episode is
titled world's finest I know that sounds
very familiar Superman Batman team-up
it's gonna be episode 18 of Supergirl
and it'll air on March 28th Grant Gustin
posted this image of his script so
they're probably getting ready to shoot
it if they haven't already started let's
see if I can turn this into like a top
10 WTF video first big question I know
you guys are asking does this officially
mean that Supergirl is part of the
arrowverse yes it does but you have to
remember it's a multiverse explainer so
largely Supergirl is gonna exist on its
own Barry will probably talk about his
adventures with Cara when he gets back
Cisco is gonna go crazy asking him
questions what was it like how awesome
was it if they can work out a licensing
deal
Cisco might even be able to vibe scenes
from it and you'll see it on the flash
but largely this episode is just gonna
be a Supergirl thing it'll be Barry
going to National City it won't be Cara
coming to Central City that will
probably happen in future years next big
question number two WTF I know
everybody's asking why doesn't Supergirl
go on flash too why is this only gonna
be a one way crossover mostly because of
budgetary reasons they shoot flash up in
Vancouver they shoot Supergirl down in
Los Angeles in the budget for Supergirl
is a lot bigger than that of the flash
so financially flash just doesn't have
the budget to accommodate that this
season they've already spent all their
money on gorilla City all this really
awesome stuff as you guys have seen
flash has some of the best special
effects on TV but if you're confused by
that which ever show is going to build
the episode if it's gonna be an episode
of Supergirl all of the budget for that
episode comes from supergirls budget so
it's not like they share a budget when
characters cross over the flash arrow
crossovers are a good example that when
they do the flash part of the flash
arrow crossovers the entire budget from
that episode comes from the Flash's
budget and the same is true for the
arrow episodes it's just the way things
are done financially like each show has
a specific budget for specific reason
number three WTF does this mean that
Stephen Amell is also going to get to
crossover with Supergirl a certain point
technically the term
the crossover will be super flash just
because there's no arrow in the
crossover Barry might make a joke about
green arrow but Stephen Amell himself
will not be involved mostly for
budgetary reasons but also for
scheduling I mean it's already a big
enough nightmare getting a Vancouver
show to crossover with a Los Angeles
show but in future years Oliver will
totally meet car at some point number
four WTF will all these shows all
crossover at the same time will it be
like flash arrow where what happens on
on one show then the next on the next
show and vice versa maybe maybe not I
think they're gonna try and keep it as
simple as possible for now just to keep
it from turning into a logistical
nightmare that's why you're not seeing
everybody on legends of tomorrow all at
the same time that show has its own
budget even though we're gonna see a
really cool version of Oliver with one
arm it's just too expensive to have all
those actors on screen at the same time
every single week so number five WTF
what I think is going to happen next
year is you'll see the normal arrow
flash crossover just like they do every
year then you'll see a flash supergirl
crossover and then you'll also see
Supergirl come to Central City but you
won't see her go on arrow or legends of
tomorrow the only two big shows crossing
over at one time not like four different
shows crossing over at one time you can
kind of already see the problem with
legends of tomorrow there's so many
characters on screen that you don't have
enough time to have really deep
character moments you can have really
fun moments but it's not like the flash
where two characters get a really
meaningful long speech together there's
just not enough time for that so I think
it'd be a nightmare if you tried to have
actors from four different shows cross
over at the same time number six WTF and
careful for spoilers from the flash I
mean I'm gonna explain the crossing over
of Earth one earth two so if they're
going to be closing all of the portals
to earth two during season two of the
flash how is the flash going to travel
the multiverse to get to National City
on whatever planet Cara's on we'll just
call it earth three for now although
technically that's crime syndicate world
in the comics here's the deal with flash
traveling the multiverse what they're
doing on flash season two right now is
trying to close all of the portals
except for the one underneath STAR Labs
they'll probably find a way to leave
that open and use it so the Jay Garrick
and Barry can go back and forth between
earth one and earth two you know just
just contain two flash stories but
they'll also probably find a way to use
that
as a portal to other Earth's one it's a
really bad asset to it just it makes
sense from a logic standpoint if you're
gonna have one portal why not find a way
to use that to travel to other Earth's
plus you get to keep that really awesome
looking set the flash has some of the
best looking sets number seven WTF what
problem could Cara have that is so big
that she needs the flash to help her out
another Justice League level here Oh
it'll probably have something to do with
the Kryptonians from the Phantom Zone
Cara's on in Maxwell Lord maybe you know
maybe surprise fun villain - Barry tends
to get the really fun villains so they
might try and throw that in there most
of the Rogues will stay on the flash
though so I'm not expecting to see
Captain Cold any of the other rogues but
here's something that's really fun
there's a character called the rainbow
Archer he's a villain from the world's
finest comics he's a Green Arrow villain
so they don't save him for the first
time the Green Arrow gets to meet
Supergirl I'm hoping that they make a
joke about a rainbow Archer rainbow
Archer we have a Green Arrow on our
earth
number eight WTF this is only happening
because a couple of suits at CBS agreed
to it
Greg Berlanti s group is the one that
produces all these shows they would love
to have them cross over a lot of the
creative teams have a lot of overlap
behind the scenes so most of the people
associated with these shows are really
pulling for big crossovers we want
Supergirl to be able to meet these other
characters but because CBS owns
Supergirl they get the final say in
whether or not they crossover early on
when Supergirl was greenlit they got a
pilot that was the very first question
everyone asked wait a minute does this
mean that Supergirl is gonna get to
crossover with arrow and flash the
president of CBS at the time was like no
we're planning on keeping her to
ourselves for now but I think they were
relatively open to a crossover that
person ended up quitting her job a new
president was appointed and then
suddenly it was like hey maybe we will
do a crossover like all the way up to
the end of last year any of the
producers any of the business people
associated with all these shows than
these networks were like you know what
we don't have any plans for a crossover
right now we haven't had any
conversations about that there's nothing
on the books cut to January when Andrew
Kreisberg who's the showrunner in the
flash he's also an executive producer on
Supergirl
he was like if we are gonna do a
crossover this season we have to figure
it out in the next month cut to now when
they're announcing it but they have a
script all
ready so number nine WTF they actually
had probably figured it out really
quickly at the beginning of the year
wrote the episode made the arrangements
and then waited to announce it till this
week why would they do that well mostly
because it probably could have fallen
apart at any moment and they wanted to
wait till they actually had a script
actually had people booked it's
scheduled everything good to go before
they announce something there are so
many movies so many story ideas so many
things that fall apart at the last
minute a Hollywood
it's amazing that anything gets made but
just for fun number 10 WTF I know some
of you have started to ask this
especially people that have read the
comic books if we're going to be
traveling to multiple different earths
does that mean we could eventually do
anti-monitor crisis on Infinite Earths
storyline that would be amazing
now we don't have the Green Lantern's we
don't have a lot of cosmic stuff going
on yet Supergirl in a couple of her
villains are as close as we've gotten to
intergalactic characters one of the
reasons why I don't think that's gonna
happen is because it sounds very
cinematic it sounds like something that
they would save for the movie universe
they're already teasing Darkseid so it
seems like all of the biggest cosmic
villains will be saved for the movie
universe let me know in the comments
what do you guys think about this big
crossover I know I haven't been doing a
lot of Supergirl videos that's mostly a
scheduling thing but there's also just
like almost half of the people on the
channel here half of you dudes they just
absolutely hate the show and it's really
hard for me to justify doing videos for
things that I know automatically half of
our community here are just absolutely
going to hate and no one's paying me to
make videos so unless I have like a
friend working on a show like Beowulf I
have a couple friends that work on that
show so I'm trying to help them out by
doing a couple videos but Supergirl like
I don't know anybody that works on the
Supergirl TV show so most of the
Supergirl videos that I plan on doing
are really just for big comic book
characters some of you have asked for
bizarro video I'll totally do bizarre
video I'm really happy to make videos
for it but usually I just try to pick
the stuff that you guys really really
want so if there are special Supergirl
videos that you guys want me to do just
let me know in the comments in new
episode of legends of tomorrow tonight
I'm still doing the reverse flash ring
giveaway that will go down in that video
why you guys wait for me to post that
you can click here for last night's
episode of arrow in the flash and you
can click here for all my Batman V
Superman Suicide Squad videos thank you
so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight